Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters with your second section of the beading chronic
line book.
Now, I didn't tell you that these are some other books that I've written that you could
download as well, but you are dealing with chronic line, you are a lot of ones, so we want
to know how to treat it.
Maybe looking at it a little bit differently than you're currently looking at it is going
to be very helpful.
Well, there's, in this section, you're going to learn about some problems with misdiagnosis
because that is the number one problem with chronic line.
If you have chronic line, you either have, we're not correctly diagnosed or not correctly
treated in the acute phase state effect.
So looking at it first, why do we have a problem with treat line anyhow?
Well, number one, line has the ability to hide, so it hides within the cell, it has the
ability to go intrace cellular.
So viruses, the way viruses work in your body, as they go intrace cellular in order to replicate
and then kill the cell, break through the cell membrane, lice you the cell, and they
have replicated multiple, multiple times, and then they go in another cell and do the
same thing.
When a virus infiltrates the cell, though typically there's a little marker that comes up on the
outside of the cell membrane, it's a little protein marker that tells the immune system
that that cell has been infiltrated by an enemy, and then that immune system, your TH1 side
of your immune system, typically a macrophage will engulf the entire cell and destroy the
virus and the cell altogether.
That's how your body kills viruses.
The reason why antibiotics don't kill viruses is partly because they can go intrace cellular
like that and antibiotics don't go intrace cellular, so understand you have cells and you
have spaces between the cells.
So that's the extrace cellular space between the cells, the intrace cellular space is inside
the cell and if something infiltrates the cell, it really can't be killed unless that marker
comes outside the cell membrane so that the immune system can engulf and destroy the whole
cell, sacrificing the cell to destroy the virus.
The problem with Lyme disease and a few other of the gram-negative bacteria is that they
have the ability to go inside the cell and they disable that marker, so that the immune system
cannot find it, so there's nothing telling a macrophage that that cell has been infiltrated,
so that's the biggest problem with treating Lyme, and by definition of the difference between
acute Lyme and chronic Lyme is sued as a beryllia bacteria has infiltrated one cell, it
is now chronic Lyme by definition.
So acute Lyme is still the Lyme, the bacteria is still either in the bloodstream or in the
extracellular spaces, it has not yet gone intracellular, so you understand that.
acute Lyme is that Lyme, the beryllia, is still either in the blood or in the extracellular
spaces, it has not yet gone intracellular.
So that's the second problem with treating Lyme is that few people understand these stages,
so when you're trying to treat chronic Lyme that has already gone intracellular, the way
you treat acute Lyme with high dose antibiotics, it seldom works unless you stay on those
antibiotics for months or years, because every time the antibiotic is stopped, now that
beryllia could go extracellular again, continue to reproduce and then hide back in the cell,
you've not killed it.
So if the antibiotics cannot get intracellular, therefore it cannot kill that second stage
and the third stage of chronic Lyme disease.
So few understand those stages, and few are still understand how to treat an autoimmune
disease, especially even recognizing that maybe this is the first time you've ever heard
that there are three stages of Lyme or somebody defines them differently, or nobody has ever
told you that the third stage of Lyme is an autoimmune disorder.
So that we are going to hit hard and heavy through this book, so if it's all due to you,
consider these couple times, because I think it'll help you a lot.
So there's three phases of Lyme, phase one is acute, phase two is chronic, defined as one
beryllia bacteria has called intracellular, it has an auto chronic Lyme, and three is auto
immune, and we'll define that as we go.
So in acute stage Lyme, you're going to learn that we want to treat that as soon as possible,
because literally we have a window of opportunity to treat it.
So acute stage Lyme is defined as the bacteria is still in the blood or in the extracellular
spaces.
It's in the blood or the extracellular spaces.
It is still killable by an antibiotic.
So you want to get that antibiotic as soon as possible, because as soon as it enters into
a cell, gets through the cell, membrane goes inside the cell, it is not completely killable
by an antibiotic anymore, and you have moved into a possible, very chronic, debilitating disorder.
So you want to treat acute stage Lyme ASAP, like immediately.
This is my problem with the test state that we're going to talk about in future pieces of
the book.
But the problem with the test state is if you have to wait at all to get the test back,
then you have a pretty good chance of it being a false negative.
You may have missed the window, because literally it is a window of opportunity, and windows do
what they, they shut.
Once those windows are shut, once that Lyme barely has got into a cellular, you're not going
to kill it with antibiotics unless you're willing to go out in a couple of years and destroy
everything else in your mind.
So you want to go to a Lyme letter, a doctor who's going to address your symptoms based
upon a clinical picture, not based upon a blood test.
So used to be back in the days of Marcus Wellme that he would use the gleaned information
from years of wisdom, or years of wisdom from his predecessors, and would be able to assess
the condition, like a good mechanic could use to assess a car.
No, oh, and that third lifter has got a problem instead of having to throw it on a computer,
et cetera, to be able to figure out what the problem is.
So it is that we've created a field of medicine that we still call medicine medical doctors,
but really their technicians, that are basically puppets of the pharmaceutical industry and have
a very difficult time making a decision, in fact many times they're legally bound to
not be able to make a decision unless they have some sort of blood test.
That is a shame and it's just a cotton pick and shame.
So unfortunately if you want to get rid of Lyme disease and you're in the acute stage,
you need to go to some doctor who's got the conditions to be able to say, you know what,
this is probably Lyme.
We live in a very high Lyme area.
It's Lyme disease time right now.
It's in the spring or early summer.
You have flu-like symptoms, you have or don't have a rash, it's probably Lyme, we're going
to put you on some antibiotics just to make sure, heck, you'll know if it was Lyme disease.
If you go on the antibiotics and it knocks it out of you right away.
So if you go on the antibiotics and it doesn't knock it out of you, then you either miss
the acute phase, you already miss the window or it might not have been a bacteria.
So antibiotics tend to work quite well on Lyme disease.
On a grabed egg in a bacteria, Lyme antibiotics work quite well if you catch it well.
It's in the bladder or the extracellular spaces.
We'll hit this board more as we go so I don't want to take too much of your time now.
But as always call our office if you have any questions and let's do this a couple times
if you need to and read the section.
See you next section.